The next excerpt is also taken from original tape W one forty eight.
Always a read fear that whatever it was spies
this year nice and seventy and we're having another war with Russia.
And one of our top secret agents
had information from the very important information that we've
been on the way to war we got off the plane and the United States has
booked let's pause and had on the waited for to see
that they had
access and he. He was the guest of the car
door and he has a little plot in his
brain and if they operated to be mislead Hardy What do
you tell the news mission. So the ignore
the miniature age and the true station and.
They miniaturize.
The ship that was made to go on the water especially look for
water did see Joe. They used to for this
purpose to well let's rise to say the germ and put it through
is a lead system with a laser gun to let them
live quite during
this whole thing they had to go through it of course
were Poles were vain and lovingly me. And isn't the time
to look for what would be noticeable when the signs of the day were poor
and small and so was the gentleness of a man who Darfur
loans
and in a lot of this mess and you know smokes. So in
the last the cotton along and they won't see that they were they had a chart
that they didn't want to sure. So well see where they were and they got caught inside the
love and. There was reason they had Grandma inside so what we know
now. We have a code little holes and won't get back to the ship was
nice so well after that that was to the back
of the Jones moving through easier than anybody made the slightest
noise I'll say it was and be blown
apart and after hour as they went out of his body you know the
ship blew biggest natural size. So if they do they got
a little blood clot that that was the alternate there we were getting
out of last time they got called up for the
laser going broke so you had a brick contacting the outside and use
partially as
a receiver is that
talk to the outside fix the laser because that's they need when
they could have done it with a knife that was the time we just made another
club so
of they fix the legs going to have no concept. So well
they couldn't tell they were near as they really made a
noise. They was a lot
up so they don't like us here it was in the brain and under stress this is
a whole ship. Bob and a nurse in a ship no
nurse
outside and goes to the ER and the ship.
Starts bottles and turn and. Finally to go through
the blood. They did a blood clot on the way back to
get caught in another vein artery. Does bear on the whole way around the brain
again and
then out pick up
a certain of they need to come out from the ice when they
die they did something to make the hear anything was
guess the canals who carried out and they had to pick it up with the
syringe and put it back on the. The table.
Then they use the machine to move learn to get the
many size four man one woman she's the.
Foreman and more lazy and lazy trying to Mays ago and
they also thought that each of those flattened guess because they have a spy in
the ship. He sort of like. Everybody was important
and
the man that read the map. He made it wrong and he was in to kill the
guy who killed who pulled out a long track of the lady with a
laser gun was a kill
guy to block the laser was happening that they suspected
her and then they suspected that red leapt because a
they had this World Pool said he said you have no time to know
about that. I suspect and the man in
charge of
the transmitter that they thought that was the reason
he was in was break contact. So then the girl. And
there's only one guy did it but that was the one who's there
who made the ship Neferet purpose.
Who had made the ship we knew. He had made for on the ground under water and not
for going to
see how many people were there in the ship
three or four men and one girl. What are you saying that.
The lady was in charge of the laser once. The ship was a map
it was well for the transmitter and the little
man he knew even he had made ships and he knew every piece of it.
So when the yes applied man you know what the six and the plane did
run out and the cook this is before they broke contact and
they couldn't breed that here because it was. And there were many
tries and the particles in the ARE be too big for them to breathe so
they had to miniaturizing the and they had moved
here. To move up
the personalities of the characters and humans but the people the
right people. There was scared. You know to
me you know how to use it ever
since they were suspicious but at the end you suspicions were
moles you know because they they all had a right to because the laser broke the
air filter one
off and the one that's the perpetrators
never wanted I say Dorothy you brought us this way into the whirlpool.
So they all were suspicious of whatever the city and then they came out of
the ice and knew all and would was glad it
was
over and they had one second to go for the go. They didn't get out no one says
we
should be there and I would say yes and
who killed in the summation and who is this man
who yesterday say you know.
OK. He
was knows the justices outside Well this man was slain
on stretcher. She was also a lot of such was in the room. But the man
was on the
stretcher while they were in his body. I
think of the
miniaturized to image that Pullman was he had the right.
This was a new travel and it looked to them and Mitchell right
looks like a process.
He was a little container. So was there
a machine they called a while
though it was a big one and pick them
up and put him out of the. Platform new deuced again.
Then they will put.
I'm
pretty sure they would put on a platform and you do
see a third to vote. Side
mostly and then and. Then they will lose to get
and reduce the size we pull back and the
was picked up for I would say. We do some of
those ten home use of an inch and then fall back in the water and then reduce
the whole thing was there but this had
a radar of some sort of radar that it
could sense where they are in
the water. So the nurse put the needle in there and pulled
up and was in there and they told you that the needle.
That's all she know and then
they and they they cleared out. Not only
that they put in blood his type of blood and the same thing and they put
his
arm in his arm and they would lose all were
both here they got caught in the world Paul two So good
to hear they were supposed to lose here.
They're going to put up on the news break. Oh.
Yes I hear you know he was came here to go on the
whirlpool of my neck and we not only don't lose
a into his lungs.
They got a long and then they go
who I think is named of a widow of
Lola violin that's the this size. Alyssa I never knew was
whose really was your any qualms with
people
you know the windows but the walls they all kept on I
just. This is this is this is this.
What what. How far you can go places.
So just like the sending
those ships are out of control those aircraft with
bombs on it and these are radio
controlled by something happens the transmitter Lou are some of the most lethal as
Nasscom was just one of the most common.
So that's a down. Yes but of I read the book already.
And I like to use again I was S.S. So how do you know
if it's good I read
the whole book and. Said.
They so Marcellus's lost all of those
people says Weston drop a bomb in New York. The bomb to
go and really look at the why they
drop the most car weapon right off. No system was involved.
New York and the president was in New York that she got to leave the
one.